[Music]
can you talk specifically about the
symptoms because we're hearing some some
conflicting information on that and then
about the transmission part because I
think that's where people are most
worried at the moment so the symptoms
are going to be just like any cold or
flu that you get they're gonna be cough
fever sore throat maybe a runny nose
maybe a little bit of GI symptoms
meaning nausea and vomiting maybe some
diarrhea and then shortness of breath is
the one that we worry about in terms of
pneumonia those are the main symptoms
and they overlap a lot with influenza
the contagiousness is that this is a
disease that's pretty contagious
compared to other corona viruses like
SARS and MERS which were scary but not
very contagious between people this is
behaving more like the other corona
viruses that cause the common cold
meaning that it can be transmitted
through coughs and sneezes and on some
of the surfaces that people have touched
if they have khakhra sneezed on their
hands that's what's making this more
scary than any of the other corona virus
outbreaks that we've dealt with in the
past this is something that transmits
very efficiently in the community and
that's why this is spreading in many
many different countries and it's not
really a containable virus because of
how easy it spreads and the fact that
many people have mild symptoms that are
indistinguishable from the cold and
they're out there doing things and
spreading this around so is that really
the number one problem that there are
probably many people that have this
right now and they simply don't know so
then they're going to the supermarket
put their hand on you know right by the
cash register or something or payment
processor and then next thing you know
they're transmitting it that's part of
the issue we know that this virus
emerged in China at least around mid
November which meant it had been
spreading probably for sometime in the
community and we had there was no
restrictions or anything like that
people were traveling all over so we
know that this seed in many countries
probably before we even knew knew it and
we had a pretty severe flu season and
because the symptoms are
indistinguishable and most people have
mild cases they were probably mixed in
and not even diagnosed and there likely
are many undiagnosed chains of
transmission in the United States that
are starting to pop up now like we saw
in in Washington State for example and
that's the issue is that we didn't know
who had this disease so we couldn't tell
them you need to isolate yourself and
protect protect yourself from infecting
others nobody did any of that in the
earliest
of this outbreak and that's what we're
left with now have run we're obviously
in some unchartered territory with
coronavirus and our plan here is to help
you make as much sense of the situation
and a non alarmist fashion as possible
if you're looking for reliable
information from experts on the front
lines of the pandemic check out our
coronavirus playlist which will keep
adding updates - right over here and to
get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe